the 2020 nfl moment that we would like
to own top shot style that's what we'll
do the first pick hinges on whether or
not i get the next question right lay it
on all right well it is odd you're right
because i was like there's like a
highlight of steph curry in a random
game that's like forty thousand dollars
and you're like i i can watch it on
youtube for free i don't understand so
that that's where it's a little weird
but here's your you don't own it oh i
know you gotta own oh you gotta own it
yeah so it seems like it's all dependent
on people wanting to own these things
and that's really the value there but
all right who what what player had the
longest play from scrimmage in the 2020
season michael
longest play from scrimmage in the 2020
season i repeated the question to buy
myself time yeah man you got it you can
think of this now
there's two running backs who had two
long run touchdown runs this year i'm
gonna help you out there's two running
backs which one of them was it
oh oh no that was last year that damian
williams went 90 and he opted out anyway
um
i'm i'm drawing a blank so i guess i'll
just just say alvin kamara i don't know
well you should at least guess derek
henry doesn't he have a 95-yard
touchdown every year yeah i know yeah
that's true but but it's not ronald
jones jones i talked to him after that
game that was the one where the panther
tried to tackle him he had that he was
watching the board and he did the high
step and got away damn it yep yes good
i'm glad that's hot that red light that
red light it screws you up when you're
under that urgency to answer the
question all right you got the first
pick all right 2020 moment i would want
to own
no
hesitation here
tom brady throwing the trophy in the
back of the boat that that's the moment
i'd want to own you give me any moment
from the 2020 season i'm starting right
there the goal not really from the
season well you know we're being ahead
of here it's being fun yep i i'd want to
own i mean look at that that's
unbelievable the goat throwing his
seventh trophy you know and we know at
this point he's got to have a little
liquor in his system and everything
i'm surprised he didn't fall in the
water about the trophy and he's scared
you know scared to death here and as
i've told you i used to jet ski in that
water it is deep so they would have had
to go way down there to get that one but
that is an unbelievable moment and we've
never seen anything like that so that
that was an amazing amazing thing to
watch
that that's that's a good one i like
that and that's the angle that's that's
awesome and you can tell as soon as you
see how that reaction that's drunk guy
reaction you're right he kind of recoils
you don't do that if you're sober
drinking but that's clear that's clear
tom brady has been in his cups as they
say all right uh wow
well i have to go to hell murray then if
you're going to leave me to hail murray
one moment that resonates even though
even though
that was the spark for the bills and the
cardinals were never really the same
after that i think they thought someone
threw a trophy to them after they pulled
off that play but that's the one play
that that i'll always remember
everything about it from the setup
the the little the little juke by tyler
murray to buy some time throwing the
ball while actually told me after the
game looking at his teammates on the
sideline his body was completely turned
when he threw that ball and they told us
a thing or two about his shoulder uh
injury and uh that uh you know that
makes the throw even more impressive so
that would be that would be my first
pick the hail murray yeah that's a good
one it's definitely one of the special
moments of the year there's no doubt
about that my next one i'm going from
the beast to nashville the derrick henry
stiff arm on josh norman that's one i'd
won if you gave me i mean that just it's
too fun to watch it really is and you
know i know josh norman pretty well he's
such a great guy and it just makes it
more fun to when i see him the next time
i can't wait to dog him for this it is
amazing uh the greatest stiff arm i
think i've ever seen i i don't mean that
disrespect but i don't think we've ever
seen a running back like that throw a
guy who's 205 210 pounds and he's
horizontal to the ground definitely one
of the moments i'll i'll never forget
this year
you know i've raised this question
before is it better to make the darrell
rivas earl thomas
business decision and avoid derek henry
or is it better to just go ahead and
take your medicine and get slammed to
the ground i got more respect for this
right here you you fight you fight i got
i'll always respect you if you come in
there fighting right and okay yeah it's
the nfl you're gonna get embarrassed
sometimes but i'll respect this any day
of the week over you know some of those
other ones you mentioned right but this
is going to live a lot longer it is it
definitely is he's going to have to say
that
we respect him but but rarely is the
caveat going to be added he could have
done like darrell rivas and earl thomas
and ran the other way or avoided derrick
henry like both of those guys did all
right next one for me uh oh boy there's
a uh the dk metcalf chase down yeah uh
buda baker and tackle him that that yeah
i'll i hate to i hate to go heavy on the
cardinals but uh that was a good
seahawks play that was amazing
everything about it spreading down the
field and catching up to him that was
great so uh you make you make it there's
there's too many good ones this one's
too easy yeah there is that definitely
that probably would have been my next
pick uh but i mean yes i mean buddha
baker is a baller and course can run but
dk metcalf as we know is park greek god
and run them down like he did from like
about 12 yards behind was unbelievable
my next one
i'm going to go with
la la la la la la jackson
yeah baby doo
and out of the locker room in cleveland
that's the play i want i want superman
coming out of the locker room out of his
iv what is fourth down no problem here i
come guys and then he saves the day and
runs out to the right and throws a
touchdown pass come on that was
unbelievable maybe the game of the year
like we talked about and that was a
really really special moment uh for
lamar jackson in the 2020 season
superman or pooper man yeah yeah well
maybe either off the title off the
toilet iv we don't know
and look i i i don't want to get too
graphic but given the amount of time he
was indisposed
it clearly was an iv because
if he if that walk to the locker room
reflected the urgency that most of us
thought it did you're back out of of the
locker room a lot faster than he was it
uh it it comes and it goes let's just
put it that way all right uh
next one for me
daniel jones trip and fall
you know
great plays it's gotta be you gotta have
some fun with it if you're going to own
a moment you got to own the moment of
daniel jones running to peter wide open
no one around he trips and falls over
nothing
that was amazing it really was
the guy was so excited he's about to run
for an 80 yard or what was it almost
like 80 yards 88 80 yards down but it
was an 80 yard run uh to where yeah he
ran himself into the ground i mean it
was really impressive not a lot of
quarterbacks could have done that but uh
certainly
he embarrassed himself and we liked him
scored a touchdown as as me and pete are
giant fans um all right that was a good
one i liked that a lot it made me giggle
all right i think i'm going to go i'm
going to go with i'm not sure what
mahomes play i want to go with here
i think i'm gonna go with the one in the
in the the ball all right i'll go the
chargers game the chargers game because
there's that ravens one right when he
backpedals for 15 yards and throws the
bomb for the touchdown but that chargers
throw week two and i think you had it on
sunday night football when we did his
best plays and i think he told you it
was his favorite throw of the year he
runs out to the right and i mean both
his feet are off the ground and he
throws a 50 yard on point missile to
tyree kill to win the football game
basically that that might have been the
most remarkable throw of the football
season so that would probably be my neck
or that is my last pick
all right and i'm gonna finish the draft
where we began tom brady ultimately
throwing the trophy from boat to boat we
never would have thought it would have
happened without or given that moment
from the thursday night game against the
bears
oh flash the four fingers right i want
the moment i want the four finger moment
where he's looking around like travolta
and pulp fiction where is every bob four
four and and then they try to cover it
up which made it even better or worse
the case may be but there it is that's
the moment i thought it i thought it's
fourth down it's not
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports